hello america i'm andrew yang and yes
i'm starting a podcast one year ago you
never heard of me but now
the biggest ideas i ran for president on
are front and center in our country
today
universal basic income to help us pay
our bills
in this tough time and even common sense
stuff like finally getting rid of
daylight savings time
and this is not a politics podcast
because i'm not much of a politician as
you can tell i lost
what we need are real solutions that
will actually improve our lives every
single day
that's what i'm interested in that's
what i think you're interested in
and me and some of the biggest figures
in
culture technology sports business and
entertainment
are going to get together and help
figure out what's coming next
they're going to be some people i talked
to that you've never heard of just some
fascinating randos
but i can guarantee you they will be
fascinating as
fascinating as they are random yang
speaks the newest podcast you never knew
you needed but now you're gonna love
find it where you find all of your other
podcasts we're not gonna hide it from
you
so please do check out yang speaks on
applespotifyradio.com and wherever you
listen to your podcasts
let's talk about the future and let's
make it work for us
yangyang out